well a local animal advocacy group is
offering thousands of dollars in rewards
to find the people they believe
abandoned their dogs now the first case
is this Doberman who was found in a
vacant trailer lot near Nellis and
Desert Inn he was stuck in a bush and
has now undergone emergency treatment
after his ears were just butchered and
then this pair of Maltese mixes are just
covered in urine and feces severely
matted neglected they were found in an
apartment complex in North Las Vegas now
Rescuers believe they're the product of
backyard breeding if you know anything
about either of these cases you can
contact Nevada voters for Animals
through Facebook or this number again
there's a thousand dollar reward for
each case and we'll have this contact
information for you on our website as
well